Here's a feminine pocket that little girls
will just love. The body of
the pocket is gathered.
The lower edge of the pocket is
joined to the sweater as it's knit.
There's a picot hem finishing the top,
and you could knit any hem you
like or even hand knit a few garter rows.
It's easy to knit, but it does take
some time to rehang the stitches.
So plan a little time for this one.
Once you've established your pocket size
and position,
cast-on your A dimension with waste yarn
and ravel cord leaving live stitches.
Knit the body of the pocket and remove
the stitches on scrap yarn or a garter bar.
Put the G needles in working position.
And return any other needles
to out of work position.
You'll rehang the scraped off edge of your
pocket on these needles,
gathering them up.
Here's a tip to make it easier to finish
the pocket. When you're rehanging,
don't double up a few of those
end needles.
Remove the waste yarn and confirm
that all the stitches are picked up.
With the gathered stitches secure
on the needles,
knit a marker row with the garment yarn
and a marker cord held together.
Use a strong ravel cord
of contrasting color.
Next, you'll knit across
all of those needles.
Now, there may be three stitches on some
needles, so knit slowly or
knit this row manually.
For  my gauge, I knit five rows
to start my hem,
or about three quarters of an inch.
Knit a turning row, I chose to transfer
every other needle for picots.
Turn your tension down about two full
numbers and knit the second half
of that ham tighter than the garment
a tension if you're right-handed, plan to
end this with the carriage on the right.
At this point, turn your tension,
back up to garment
tension before you forget.
Next, you'll hang the marker row
on the needles,
leave a tail at least three times
the width of the pocket,
breaking the working yarn.
And sew off all those stitches by pulling
that tail of yarn through
each one of the stitches.
We used a double-eye needle,
but you could use a yarn needle or
a darning needle.
Carefully, remove a few stitches,
pull the tail through,
remove a few more stitches,
pull the tail through and continue
until all the stitches have
been removed from the machine.
Now, you might be tempted to bind off
these stitches, but by using this method,
there will be a little more stretch
for the pocket opening so you can get your
hand in. Secure the tail
and remove the marker cord.
And set the pocket aside.
Cast-on and knit your garment
to the point where you want
the bottom of the pocket to start,
remove all the stitches from the machine
with a garter bar or scrap them off.
Next, with the knit,
the right or the public side,
whatever you want to call it,
it's the public-facing side of the pocket
facing you, hang the lower edge of the
pocket on the corresponding needles.
You're going to hang live stitches
from that ravel cord edge of the pocket.
And as before, you're going to double up
stitches, gathering them in to fit
the number of needles that you need.
You may want to remove the scrap at this
point and confirm that all the stitches
are securely on the needles.
Make sure that all the stitches
are behind the latches.
Next, rehang the garment on the needle
bed with the wrong side facing that purl
side needs to be facing you,
putting the garment stitches
in the hooks of the needles.
Carefully pull those garments stitches
through the pocket stitches.
Continue knitting the garment piece.
When your garment is complete,
finished the pocket by neatly stitching it
in place and voila,
beautiful, feminine, gathered pockets.